good morning thank you very much for
coming maybe I yo come a long long way
folks ever before your sons and
daughters have shown up I felt like I
came a long way that one watches where
to slow her down a half but I think I've
done after the last 20-odd years but
I've met people here already come from
Canada branch safaris India and come a
long way some of you may know in order
by the name of Matt Ridley Matt recently
wrote a book called rational optimist
how wealthy boss but you may have read
an essay you bro Wall Street Journal
homily freedom and his point was now you
just called why humans trying why have
all the species in this world or unit
being raised to the top and first he
said is it because of our intellect is
it because of all the skill set we
develop his answer is really none he
broke it down early on critical trade
but what he used the term trade was
cultural exchange intellectual
information exchange that made us
different and he said that this
eventually came sexualized institutions
such as Columbia University and instead
over time what happens is this cultural
exchange this accumulation of
information going back and forth create
innovation innovation in many fields now
we have leaving the field of Dentistry
but he said if you actually sit down
when you think about it he says you take
a pan out of your pocket never your
visual actually
pain from start to finish cleaning
figured out how to make the ink how to
put it into the pen how to take the pen
to a store how do the liver pain to you
and so on and so forth you know how to
basically use it in day-to-day life
think about your ipod you all have your
iphones everyone has even though Steve
Jobs is considered a genius he'll love
not a developer that based on human live
cultural exchange then he says the next
thing is over time what we wind up doing
is we create specialization we narrow
our focus we create more information by
coming very very narrow about what we do
but we need places do that and this is
what you are all that you all came to
columbia one way or the other you found
your way here to develop a
specialization to become very very now
in your skill sets now sometimes people
say well that's bad only certain upside
though is is that the groups of
specialists come together and you become
very harrowing folks but yet you buy
information from each other your skin
parents ranks look at the size of this
room you're about 60 people here think
about the dynamic exchange that your
sons and daughters have had economy
doubtful for the last two three four six
years becomes remarkable and so
basically what here today to honor your
a dedication to their specialization be
that broad exchange of information what
daughter is learning from periodontist
periodontal flirting
ended up so today also parents relatives
ran significant others to show you the
importance of this what it means to this
dental school okay you see we have 17
people up on this dais all to help in
this celebration start out with our Dean
Dean IRA Lamster followed by dr. Mary
monger she's the Centennial professor in
health policy and the Dean of the School
of Nursing once again we have the demon
school nursing here celebrating
postgraduate education at the dental
school dr. salen teen who you'll meet
later on our Vice team we have our
university chaplain Reverend Davis next
to her we have dr. Charles Solomon he's
the interim director division of
endodontics not to him is the program
director of endodontics dr. Gunnar
hassle friend then from orthodontics we
have dr. Thomas Angelo see he's the wild
professor and chairman also the section
of growth and development next to him we
have margarita Santoro the program
director then we have the professor and
chair of the section of oral and
diagnostic sciences dr. pop open oh and
he's also the division director of
periodontics next then we have a
prosthodontist the director Shelby white
next to him Phil Turman who's the
director of advanced education and
general dentistry program dr. steven
justin is our director of pediatric
dentistry and with him is his program
director dr. Richard noon dr. David
Zagar Ellie is the professor director of
the division of oral pathology and
finally next to him is dr. Sidney Isaac
who is the Gutman professor of clinical
craniofacial surgery and director of all
maxillofacial surgery so once again a
distinguished panel to help in this
celebration
when people ask me about the overall
university itself one of the things that
I always state is that the next
individual who's been with this
university for over 15 years is one of
the reasons you really want to come here
okay I think she's been a wonderful
chaplain for this institution and for
our invocation I think we're extremely
fortunate to have Reverend Davis it's
always such a pleasure to join with the
College of Dental Medicine this ends my
commencement season for this year and
and I so enjoy the opportunity to be
with such a wonderful group of people
hear these words oral health and
Dentistry are critical aspects of health
care in this country and around the
world your specialized training research
skills and diagnostic expertise put you
at the center of some of the most
important health concerns of many
children men and women today you will
not only work to close the gap in oral
health disparities you will give early
warnings of serious chronic and systemic
health conditions the impact of your
work will your that your work will have
on the quality of life for women and man
children and elderly is significant and
in some cases life-saving may God grant
each of you the current and the humility
to be humane partners and health
management gentle and compassionate
healers may God's mercy empower you to
be generous listeners wise practitioners
and patient researchers may each of you
be blessed with a curious mind good
humor and a peaceful spirit may it be so
maybe so with God
Thank You Reverend Davis I would now
like to have the odd Dean IRA lamp stir
come and start our ceremony Thank You
Jimmy and good morning to you all I
certainly want to welcome all of you
here today to this graduation ceremony
for our postdoctoral students and
residency programs for 2010 as you heard
this is the last event of our
commencement season and for many of you
it marks the end of your formal
education as we all know education
continue at continues throughout life
but some of you may actually have to
join the workforce these postdoctoral
and residency programs are an essential
part of the educational mission of the
Columbia University College of Dental
Medicine and they are among the best of
their kind in the nation entry criteria
into these programs is really quite
competitive the alumni have a terrific
sense of camaraderie and shared
experience furthermore many of the
graduates of these programs have been
and continue to be leaders in the
profession a number of these programs
have been in existence for many decades
in fact orthodontics for more than 85
years periodontics for more than 60
years in endodontics for more than 40
years that history certainly emphasizes
the fact that these programs have helped
shape the College of Dental Medicine as
dental specialists and well-trained
generalists you enter the profession
that's certainly an interesting and
challenging time despite the economy the
opportunities remain to outstanding
there also is a new focus on the
importance of oral health as part of
primary health and new diagnostic and
treatment approaches are routinely being
introduced I only need to point out how
osseointegrated implants have changed
this profession during the last 20 years
and how now the focus on the
relationship of oil inflammation
systemic diseases continues to ask cause
us to ask how does dental medicine fit
into the larger healthcare system as you
enter the next phase of your
professional lives there will be many
pulls on your time but remember that you
have a responsibility to the profession
into your patients to be part of the
change
and change curves constantly further do
not forget your families in your loved
ones achieving a balance between the
professional and the personal will be a
constant struggle for all of you you
will work hard but I urge you to find
time for rest and relaxation today is a
time for celebration and acknowledgement
of what each of you has accomplished my
congratulations to you and your families
and on behalf of the College of the
limited medicine I wish you a most
successful future in addition to my
opening remarks I have the opportunity
to introduce today's guest speaker
traditionally what we've done is ask a
leader from the Columbia University
Medical Center who is not a member of
the dental profession to speak to our
graduates impart some important words
and today we've invited dr. Mary Oh
neomonde eager to be that the
commencement speaker dr. Monday guard as
you heard is the Centennial professor in
health policy in Dean of the Columbia
University School of Nursing she is an
elected member of the Institute of
Medicine the American Academy of Nursing
and the new york academy of medicine she
is the founder of the columbia advanced
practice nurse associates the first
nursing school faculty practice where
nurse practitioners helped commercial
managed care contracts and are
compensated at the same rate as primary
care physicians recently she established
the first Doctor of Nursing Practice
degree in the United States and 1998 she
was named the nurse practitioner of the
year but the nurse practitioner the
American Journal of primary health care
in 1984 1985 doctor monday who served as
a Robert Wood Johnson health policy
fellow in the office of Senator Edward
Kennedy person she maintained a
relationship with until his death in
1996 1996 excuse me she was awarded a
Doctor of Humane Letters from Hamilton
College she is a noted expert on health
policy known primarily for her work on
workforce issues and primary care I'm
really very pleased to introduce dr.
good morning I'd like to offer my
congratulations to each of you on your
magnificent accomplishments this is a
day unlike your first professional
degree attainment and one that marks
your achievement of extraordinary
competence and provides a new swelling
of pride among those who love you and
guided you toward this day it is a day
of great joy for them and for you in
these brief moments before you share
this day with your family and friends I
would like to convey to you three
perceptions about you in your careers
first you have reached a pinnacle of
Education and confidence that you can
reach celebrate wildly then get down to
work those following your progress are
not expecting you to only sustain the
practice protocols you learned in your
residency they are glancing up from
evaluating your progress on those tasks
to see how you are using your training
are you fully utilizing what you learned
are you in a set path or are you
breaking new ground what does your
practice and tail how are your patients
faring how are you faring in your
profession and in your communities as a
person 50 years in her profession and
half that time as a Dean I can tell you
with some confidence that your
contributions will and must be far
greater than excelling at the status quo
already established in your specialty
regardless of how valuable that
specialty and that status quo
today but first you must season yourself
in your new roles maintain your student
approach of inquiry and confirmation as
you gain ever more confidence in your
decisions and in your skills seek
guidance and ask for assistance you are
not a finished product the luster of who
you will become is dependent on these
early days of a continued search for
proof that you are mastering your craft
second meet your obligation to build new
improved practice protocols as a
clinical professional you already know
the value of utilizing evidence in your
practice now your task is to expand on
that and begin the thoughtful carefully
designed meticulous process of building
new science as your field expands and
changes this will require partnerships
between practice and research you must
begin those partnerships early and make
them part of the fabric of your work
your rare and precious clinical gift to
this partnership will be your
observations your analysis the aha
moment when you begin to see
similarities and how your patients
respond to care or develop ideas based
on clinical problems with a common theme
you will be the one in such a
partnership to guide the path of new
inquiry based on evidence this is how a
profession the tours and it advances
your clinical acumen and your research
partnerships are crucial to that dynamic
lastly your generation as in all
clinical professions more than those of
the past understand the importance of
breaking down conventional scope of
practice firewalls illness and disease
no no such boundaries and the needs of
individuals require that the clinician
caring for them can think beyond the
traditional barriers of practice
this is not an invitation to be Cowboys
or cowgirls in your approach nor should
any clinician act outside the limits of
one's tested confidence however this is
an invitation to consider how your
profession should break out of the
bounds of oral health and oral disease
as a nurse I know that systemic illness
and disease can sometimes be identified
through the eyes and hands of you and
your colleagues with a current and
drastically worsening shortage of
primary care clinicians why shouldn't
some in your profession gain the added
authority and advance patient access to
care in this medical specialty of
primary care of the observations I have
shared with you about your career
progression it is the third one that is
so germane to why your Dean asked me to
join you here today IRA is a proponent
of all three of these observations he
has been a stealth advocate with a
direct voice he has a plan and the steps
toward that plan are transparent the
goal however is a little foggy ER in the
public eye are you really going to be a
central part of the conventional medical
establishment if not why change the name
of your school to include the word
medicine what an extraordinary leap of
expectations this signals to its
graduates IRA not only espouses these
goals he lives them he is a scientist
who knows the political process
necessary for change and he believes
that you can be the instruments of
change I have consciously not used the
name of your profession in my remarks
today
this is not because I believe your
profession like nursing in the past has
not been inadequately recognized but
rather because I believe your work will
far exceed the traditional expectations
of the graduates and the professional
titles of those who preceded you this is
simply a call to arms from one of your
nursing colleagues be all you can be and
congratulations Thank You Dean for those
wonderful remarks if if you look around
right now you'll and you're not familiar
with people at this institution your
sons and daughters can point out that
many of the staff and administration
have basically come down out of their
clinical areas and everything to help in
this graduation and everything and I
think what that points out is the
quality of our both our staff and their
dedication to this institution and our
residents and our post Doc's right that
that were all willing to gather on on
this special day so I applaud our staff
out there today thank you for coming
down
well I know everyone's saying enough's
enough talking enough speaking right dr.
Lipton thaw let's move this along okay
even though if you were here we you know
probably one of the most beloved program
directors over 20 years that I've seen
because because his residents always
seem to cry when he when he does the
introductions is dr. gunner house over
in for certificate in endodontics dr.
house or green good morning this is a
day of celebration so congratulations to
all graduates and your families and
loved ones who have supported you we
have an endodontics a fantastic class
class that has gone through obstacles
that no other class and many more
obstacles have been thrown at them than
any other class but they handled it well
and handled it with grace and may I ask
you to come up one at a time
alphabetical order we have first doctor
to Don Elijah who originally came from
hell
we have dr. Martian Donnie from Syria
who is not here because of his mother's
demise unfortunately we have dr. Khalid
Khan who just arrived because of traffic
i assume he's originally from Iran where
he was already an under Dantas but he
wanted to go deeper into our field we
have dr. J oh who is a Columbia product
dr. Typhon who has a past at Columbia as
a beach in forum ecology and via umdnj
in New Jersey he came here and we have
dr. hoshino ripped amaka from Japan many
will not recognize him without his
camera but he's here so congratulations
to all of you
one of the time-honored traditions here
is that we have a usually have one of
the residents come up and make a few
closing remarks for their discipline
who's the resident all right come here
where's she going the script is
did you write that script new warm it's
in friendship you better there's a story
of a young dentist that just started his
own clinic he rented a beautiful office
and had it furnished with antiques
someone's paying attention paintings and
a waiting room full of magazines he set
hour after hour an opening day hoping
for someone to come by for treatment
after some time he saw man approaching
the office wishing to appear busy the
new dentist picked up the phone and
pretended he was giving an appointment
finally he hung up and turned to the
visitor who was waiting behind the desk
can I help you ask the dentist yes the
man replied I've come to activate the
phone line
well this may be where we're heading
soon there are definite challenges that
lie ahead and getting started in the end
o business may be daunting at first but
our time here has given us a good
springboard from which we will all
hopefully enjoy wonderful careers and
what I consider to be the best specialty
sorry guys good morning everyone I'd
like to welcome all the friends and
family members who have come from all
over to celebrate this exciting day with
us unfortunately one of our co residents
is not able to be here today hey Marsha
Donny lost his mother this week and his
home in Syria with his family we sent
him our deepest condolences and wish
that he could be here with us on this
special day I would now like to thank
our chairman dr. Solomon who has joined
us this past year he's been a dedicated
individual who strives to enhance our
endodontic program here at Columbia but
bringing energy and enthusiasm to the
task dr. Solomon is my honor today to
present you this gift as a token of our
appreciation Jay has it
we would like to thank our program
director dr. hasslein very much for all
of his health and all the faculty
members who have been there to guide us
along the way with advice knowledge and
experience as we close this chapter in
our lives we look forward to joining all
of you as colleagues in the world of
endodontics special round of applause
dr. hospital Thank You Kerry and I hope
you're here for Vega awesome assistant
and making the residents in all the
other departments jealous Mohammed we
thank you and we're really glad you're
able to join us this year and appreciate
all your hard work and help you're here
too and thanks to the front desk for all
your help me Todd Denise we will miss
you I was told to keep my speech under
three minutes so I had to keep it short
or speak fast so I'm going with the
former I'd like to congratulate my co
residents in endo and all my fact all my
fellow residents and the other specialty
departments as well I wish all of you
the best of luck wherever your past
maybe it was a pleasure working with all
of you and I hope the relationships
we've established here continue on past
these days here in Colombia
Thank You endo our next group is for the
Masters North Adonis their program
director dr. centaurs when the hardest
working program directors I know she's
always always on yes she's looking she's
always on the go dr. Santoro please come
up who presents thank you Jim good
morning everyone I expect big cheers for
my students when they come up and please
help me welcome them and I invite them
one to one by one to join us on the
stage starting with a column who's
saying hello truly deserves all the
shears and much more he joined us from
the dental school at virginia university
has a background in biomedical
engineering he actually turned down a
security shin to another program to take
a chance to match at columbia university
and we are fortunate he did he has been
interested for us the joke among the
faculty is that is that now that we have
a fully digital clinic we should also
quite a cloning device to give a double
local image plants an impact about class
president is input has been invaluable
to promote improvements in our programs
is an exceptional clinician intelligent
researcher friendly and supportive
classmate an in difficult situation he
has the plan of James Bond he will
relocate to Washington DC after
graduation we're glad is no moving too
far tell him I would like to personally
thank you for your help there's been a
privilege to work
Jeffrey Liam Jeffrey joined us from UCSF
and during dental school he had
participated in laboratory research on
the apoptosis or periodontal ligament
cells but truly creative California
personality have to rejoin our program
he quickly adapted to the uptight East
Coast cultural standards and eventually
changed his original hairstyle to a more
conservative one Jeffrey we still have
the original features Jeffrey has an
engaging personality always were smiling
the clinic and makes every effort to
blend in the environment I sometimes
hear his voice during lectures mumbling
at the back of the classroom I'm sure
one day he will reveal his real thoughts
on biomechanics congratulations Jeff
same yelling Sylvia is originally from
taiwan now a Long Island resident she's
a graduate of Columbia dan of the
Columbia dental program where she
collected an impressive series of owners
she came with the strongest
recommendation from our economy faculty
especially by the maxillofacial surgeons
in fact after gaining enough exposure to
the surgical field Sylvia made a smart
choice I'm sorry said because very smart
shoes have research on the skeletal
effect of a bipedal expansion could
truly modify the way orthodontist
practice and besides that city has
maintained a challenging patient pool
managing numerous complex craniofacial
patients she is considered quite
efficient and a very sincere honest
person Sylvia congratulations Tiffany
medicine kristensen Tiffany also
deserves all these years Apollonia
dangled right as well
with an extensive collection of honor
grades she truly impress your semantics
faculty during your undergraduate
rotations and aced the interview an
efficient class co-president along with
Killian tiffany's of go getter
multitasking over cheering clinically
and academically it would never appear
stressed because tiffany is the queen oh
cool involved in a variety of students
organizations and very gregarious she
has been the official tour guide her
dental school applicants in past three
years while managing the bed intense
clinical schedule she also found the
time and energy to teach the columbia
dental students during the imminent
clinics her vacation time went to
organized weddings heroine wedding and
to being a bridesmaid in friends and
family weddings I can easily imagine our
baking a cake in the office in between
seem patience and making phone calls to
the stockbroker tiffany is planning to
practice in near city we are a year to
year of our successful future career
congratulations chisel to Vivian Gisele
joined our programs from UCLA dental
school where she also worked in
pharmacology and psychology research
investigating cognitive development she
moved to the east coast super sewer
dental degree at Harvard she said very
high standards for herself investing
time and resources in achieving them and
enjoys the challenge a very inquisitive
person without attention to detail she
can provide surprisingly complex answers
to apparently simple questions one can
certainly say that she has an
orthodontic personality Gisele is still
undecided of other future whereabouts
and maybe go back to the golden coast of
California but with their impeccable
chairside manners and friendliness we
have no doubts that she would succeed
anywhere she decides to be
congratulations Stephanie sue
originally from Taiwan after graduating
from Berkeley in San Francisco Stephanie
moved to Harvard to complete a dental
degree wala Harvard should research on
vascular smooth muscle cell
proliferation and our supervising
faculty members were so sorry to see her
leave but Boston was too small for a
creative thinker like Stephanie it does
not take too many words for her to
clearly convey the message she plans to
deliver and one can be sure that she has
carefully pondered the answers and has
eliminated all unnecessary and
cumbersome flourish stephanie has a true
scientific mind she's honest and candid
with superb work ethics she pursues
clinical excellence but always
prioritizing with patients interest and
is one student faculty could trust to
work with minimal supervision
congratulations Stephanie well done
volume go is a Columbia dental graduate
with the strongest recommendations as
well by faculty she participated in
microbiology research on varied on top
antigens then she decided to gain
experience in private practice for a few
years before applying to orthodontic
programs bo is an excellent and
scrupulous clinician with a quiet
demeanor soft-spoken caring and gentle
she's a lady even the most difficult
patients end up mellowing under her care
Boaz assaulted common sense she's well
organized a truly hard worker ezel exits
constructive criticism she's managed
three years in a busy specialty program
while nurturing the young child and a
husband and as one more child due
shortly we try not to get much stress
emotional owner discuss three days were
not equipped for perinatal care but with
their quiet demeanor book and really
manage overload with ample confidence in
the future professional achievements her
patients will be lacking did
congratulations lady Bo well class of
we are set the template for excellent
and passion for your specialty that
would be an example for many years to
come I hope you enjoyed your tenure here
Columbia as much as we enjoyed working
with you you will be truly missed and
best of luck to you all I will now hold
out your cancellation for the
distribution of integrins
and I will invite mouth
now I win by two of my students for a
very very brief speech and the two class
presidents will actually cost share they
a speech so this might be a little less
brave than some and we were told but
anyway um Dean lab start doctors can
jealousy and Santoro faculty dear family
and friends we are honored to address
you on behalf of our class one of the
first things dr. Michelle taught us was
about Australian wires they're resilient
and have the property of maintaining
their integrity even when subjected to
forces and loads We certainly have tried
to be Australian these past few years
when faced with both expected and
unexpected challenges we are
inordinately grateful for our experience
at Columbia and are amazed at how
quickly three years vanished those
fateful few months are luckily a distant
memory doctors can jealousy and santoro
we really thought you were trying to get
rid of us right from the start not only
were our fingers blistered from wire
bending but we were sitting in a room
with the thermometer reading 50 degrees
with the noise of construction outside
our window but we learned to toughen up
our resilience at time surprising even
to us we were able to fully immerse
ourselves in orthodontics in and out of
the clinic we feel privileged and
fortunate to be the last class to learn
tip edge clinically from dr. maestro to
learn the intricacies of OD TP from dr.
you on and to enjoy the tranquility of
literature review with dr. Stratis
before her wonderful retirement to
Greece while we were saddened by the
loss of some of the members of our
Columbia family we are grateful for the
hard work of dr. Santoro seagull lifer
and standing and all other faculty who
helped us to regain our strength at a
challenging time you have made each one
of our experiences more fulfilling and
beneficial of course we must thank dr.
Cangelosi for keeping the department
functional during this time dr.
Cangelosi you have been the light and
guidance of our program for 20 years you
have influenced numerous generations
orthodontist and the program will
certainly miss you and your leadership
as you step down as chair of the
department we also have a lot of other
people to thank for for helping us along
the way our hygienist April our
assistant who numerous of them who have
helped us along our journey Elsa Judy
Carmen Mindy and iono who has been with
us at the end and two that have been
with us the whole time up there gemara
smita and lily let me tell you something
will you guys have all been great we're
really going to miss you guys thanks for
being patient with us especially at the
end when things get crazy every year our
front desk staff mr. Tom Cologne I'm not
sure if you're here but you've done an
amazing job and all the ladies in the
front Carmen beninia your let Denise
Natasha Jeanette Marlene Ethel who we
hope you're enjoying the retirement and
Jessica are my best patient keep wearing
your retainers big thank you to all you
guys I a mess and everybody else who
keeps the clinic functional our
department administration Mary and
Rachel I think I saw upstairs you two
have been absolutely amazing thank you
for looking out for us being patient
with us and supporting us and anybody
else we have forgotten I'm sorry but we
owe you guys a lot of things and we
can't forget our family and friends we
have today our parents spouses siblings
in laws and even our class daughter Dana
sitting over there a lot of whom have
flown from all over the country to be
with us today we're happy to be able to
share our special moments today with you
it's been a long road for all of us
thank you for supporting us emotionally
and definitely financially for a lot
poorer now than we started we wouldn't
be who we are today if it wasn't for you
guys and we only standing here today at
our academic pinnacle because of your
love and devotion through the years and
all our friends and co residents who we
appreciate your companion companionship
you have provided we've been through
many transitions with the program and
are appreciative to all those who have
read work details for us and stepped up
to feel bigger shoes when external
forces were seemingly unbearable through
this we experienced how the Columbia
family relies on each of its members and
learn how to be a family within hour
long class we learn to rely on each
other not only as chair partner and
sherry partners and clinical colleagues
who shared orthodontic dots but also a
standing systems for board studying as
travel buddies and advice givers for
life's major
as we graduate each of us is reminded
daily of what we will miss the
personality quirks and support of our
classmates and all the great times we
shared together so we just want to say a
little thing about each of our
classmates so we'll start bow bow the
quietest among us yet the most generous
in giving in heart we're so happy you
were brought into our lives and brought
Dana and sang with you we look forward
to meeting your new little girl in two
months we are positive she will be as
adorable and full of personality is Dana
and is kind and wonderful as our super
mommy Giselle our self-appointed social
chair our entire clothes class allows
you a lot for being sort of a punching
bag and taking a lot of blows that were
given out we knew we can always rely on
your patients and their numerous broken
brackets for comic relief when stressful
times in clinic your generosity and
willingness to organize birthday
get-togethers and other social
activities has been instrumental in
keeping us together as a class and we
thank you for that Sylvia perfect in
every way literally who knew you'd even
be perfect and hit the bullseye your
first time with a dart ever in your hand
your precision brilliance and
willingness to help never ceases to
amaze me it has been a pleasure to spend
dental school and residency with you
even if I may have scared you a little
bit of times my yelling we look forward
to watching your perfection involve into
practice like MBL staff You certainly
have a lot of competitiveness packed
into your small frame your love of
sports has been a welcome belief for
Jeff and me in a class flowing with
estrogen I'm not sure how you put up
with Jeff for three years though but I'm
so glad it wasn't me I had to do it your
caring personality and selflessness was
a much needed climbing presence during
the craziness at the end and during the
job hunt process we wish you the best
with your new job in Jersey even though
you don't fit the bill of a jersey I at
all Jeff even though you're the class
clown some of our most prominent
memories of you ironically have been
while you're asleep our only quiet time
of the day however our days especially
Lily's wouldn't have been the same
without your loud voice blatant honesty
and constant smile we're so happy you
brought Jojo to our coast and into our
lives even if she did expand our waist
lines a little bit with her delicious
cookies we know your personality would
lead you'd only two great things back in
California and we look forward to
sharing them all with Tiffany my partner
in crime today and throughout the three
years that's Court president of this
class she's always been too emotional
one of the class she almost made it all
the way through six weeks of wire
bending but alas she broke down the
second to last day along with her typo'd
on she's the queen of postage as I found
always at least ten lying around or a
cabinet on a daily basis not to mention
the two or three she always carries
around in her phone and then I can say a
lot about her clumsiness but i'll just
mention it here instead of going into
details but in all seriousness you've
been a great leader organizer and
spokesperson for the class i'm not sure
how i got to be the one that was
fortunate enough to have had you in my
bay for two years and as my chair
partner this past year but I'm truly
grateful for it my experience of
Columbia would not have been the same
without you and even beyond clinic it
was absolutely delightful getting to
know you better as the person that you
are thank you for putting up with me and
being a great friend I'll miss you okay
and now I have to try to get through his
so clean you're probably one of the
smartest people I know I admire your
attention to every detail perhaps even
semi OCD lucky Sarah does for Oreo
cookies at a glass of milk at exactly
the same time every night bring about
you have been an amazing example for all
of us to follow in the clinic I'm
confident that your successes with Sarah
and Virginia will be numerous and I
can't wait to see them unfold however
brilliant aside I most admire your
attention to detail in your
relationships it was a quick transition
for us from classmates who SAT across
from each other reading each other's
thoughts through mask faces to study
partners texting buddies life coaches
orthodontic husband and wife no offense
to Sarah or Evan but most importantly to
the best of friends you've helped me in
so many ways technologically following
in true Indian tradition academically
and emotionally you get me and all of my
faces and there's no one I rather or
could have spent the past
years I'll miss you incredibly but I
know with every piercing beep of my
phone throughout each day I will look
forward to words of encouragement
questions and updates from you so this
fabulous group is ready we are eager to
make the next step in our orthodontic
careers unfortunately we find ourselves
in a difficult position to the current
economic climate as job opportunities
aren't exactly what we had hoped for and
imagined but this is just one more
challenge in our path we remain
optimistic for the future knowing that
we have been well educated and have a
support system behind us even though
none of us individually were like those
Australian wires we wanted to be our
shared experiences are what helped us to
maintain integrity become resilient and
prepared us to face the challenges ahead
will soon be going our separate ways
around the nation but we will take a
piece of each of our classmates and
experiences with us as our strength
I think north of donek just movements a
little faster than that but that's all
right
Nick we are buried we had relapse
already
Margaret's a little ortho humor okay i
do carry on you were better that's for
another night I forgot we had a pareo
program I need dr. Papa panels help so
you can come up with me we'll get out
we have two residents who have been
receive a Masters of Science in
periodontics dr. karen md karen uh we
have a national examination every year
and she's one of the top scorers
throughout the whole country
consistently over the last three years
Julian the Newark also receiving RMS
every year I asked some resin to become
an expert to small little niche and
Julie took on microscopic surgery for us
and has done a couple of fantastic
presentations we have three certificate
recipients dr. John Choi who received
his dental degree from CDM John
volunteered several times to do our
grand rounds or evening grand rounds the
next one is dr. chetan patel chain
cleaner with a PhD Jake was great on
organization needs a natural
entrepreneur and he never lets me forget
that he has a ph.d near war to Sean
North brother's an oral maxillofacial
surgeon he resisted that urge I'm glad
that he did you decide to become a
periodontist your brother over there
sorry doc you couldn't ask for in
anytime I needed something done any help
for any assignment noir was always there
so as a group there one the best you
spent as a program director you spend
more time your residence right dr. Isaac
than your own family so well worth it
Julie Lemieux right you have been voted
the speaker okay Raja Muda you know the
mess in a family discover new jewelry
I'm sorry just in case you haven't
realized yet some on the French one and
we have two other French speaking fancy
dance as well now I want Karen all right
so I'm going to continue in English so
when I'm beyond formica residence we'd
like to thank our family for the loving
support a boyfriend and girlfriend for
standing by a seven through a difficult
time we'd like to sign particularly like
a fine the top of the panel and it goes
to third not only because they were
quite faculty and motels but also
because they have the ability to pick
amazing resident like myself
Victor fine with your sense of humor and
your dedication we are fun finally able
to survive the 36 months of labor
without side effects I mean I'm not
talking for now but the cattle panel
with your Greek Swedish personality you
are always pushing us to achieve a
higher level of perfection now we can
tell you that we appreciate what you did
for us Evan so we didn't seem quite
awake during currently thanks to the
toffee Victor super your loving and
caring personality made us feel like we
had a second mother away from home you
are always there for us and we were
blessed to a set amount o in our life
the wise philosopher once said at the
end of the day the strength of this
program as a resident and Victor fine
was right because believe me those
people are amazing they're really on top
of the game and then not only just
create periodontist of course the more
importantly they're great people during
those three years I'm not only my
colleague also made friends and even
more I find twins or my sister thank you
guys for those three years thank you for
being there with lacquer suited sank our
co-ed done from the other departments
not only will a colleague but we also
partner in crime and we will miss you
and wish you the best for your future
carrier graduation guys with a corset to
thank our faculty for inspiring and
guiding us for this adventure who are
lucky to be surrounded by such great
perdon tests and they very great model
for our future Altaria so I would I hope
I won't forget any name
redacted time doctor she lying whores
man Donna was Canali la la CGR saving
cash Pitman may choose shortest butter
ball denise's and Kim and Ken came over
the toe of dr. jariabek and it off wats
of course we won't forget Elena schwate
hygienist she is doing an amazing job
and she was wigging out like we were her
own daughter and son we would like also
to thank the supportive staff which
without them will be totally lost Jenny
I don't know if it there of course thank
you for being this eccentric person that
you are and interesting as during our
period ends thank you for being yourself
min the girls and Yolanda I don't know
if they were wrong you have always
available for us and we appreciate your
time and you helped so working with us
in the clinic wasn't easy everyday
especially with me so we like to thank
our assistance Judy sherry eres also era
and shelter and yes system from the
other department especially carry
falando carry thank you thank you so
much for giving us an opinion last but
not least we won't forget the front desk
you're Layton Denise and you are such
sweet sweet art and thank you so much
for your kindness so more personally
three years ago I left everything behind
me to to coming this program for me it
was a dream and today it's an
accomplishment so it was an incredible
experience and now I'm doing it for work
to be in front of you and to be next to
my new family the pair you can be a
family so I guess my now we have to
start our life is just beginning
and I just have to say congratulation
class of 2010
ok the next program is masters of
science and prosthodontics their program
director dr. Shelby white and I dr.
house we would always teach a course at
eight in the morning on wednesday
morning she'll be used to think the
course was at age 15 but i really love
shelby come on up well i would like to
congratulate all the graduates this year
and also i like to congratulate the
parents you should be very proud of all
your your children sons and daughters
who are finished in this program
recently John Wooten passed away and
there are some expressions that he left
with us and one of them was success and
a judge success up by how hard a person
worked to enable them self to be the
best they could be I look at not only my
residence and prosthodontics look at all
the residents in this school and I think
that all of you are truly successful
within these four years three years how
we say four years I'm sorry my residents
are like family to me the hardest thing
and like I said last year was I always
keep thinking the last name is white so
I have to you know make sure that I
pronounce their last names correctly but
I'm really not sorry that there they'll
leave it I know they're going to be
doing fantastic things as they proved
throughout the three years they were
here so I'd like to bring my for
residents to the stage right now I like
to start off with Nicole Mackay who are
our emotional member of our towers and
very talented member
of our of our graduating group I like to
bring up Jay Peck who brought me through
all Korea last year fasten Ikki wrap
wrap up alone and my youngest son a
young sean again I'm proud of all of you
and I'm looking for great things like I
know you are you're all successes thank
you very much for the three usually
hello everyone on behalf of my class we
would like to thank our parents for
supporting our challenges and
celebrating our successes to our
Columbia faculty you allowed us to set
standards that exceeded the bar you
encouraged us promoted us and set
Herculeah expectations these
expectations have created us to
continually seek options and device
treatment plans in the best interest of
our patients health thank you to
columbia university for promoting our
residents to excel and be lifelong
learners we would like to thank dr.
white all of our wonderful attendings
dr. salen tyne all of our professors who
have been so instrumental in our
education our staff you let Delia Millie
all the front desk all the assistants
and every other personnel who is
facilitated and helped us for the past
three years we would like to thank our
colleagues in perio oral surgery and no
an ortho for working together and
learning how to be a team for this we
will continue to network serve others in
the realms of education health business
and charity and always remain humble and
in signified to everyone we are
appreciative for all that you have done
and look forward to the future as we
remain a part of the Columbia University
College of Dental Medicine family Thank
on the tombstone probably one of the
world's greatest entertainers is written
the phrase the best is yet to come so
now we have dr. Phil sermon and the AEG
deprogram good morning and welcome to
all the families who've traveled from
all over the world literally all over
the world to be here to share any
success of this wonderful HD program
which in itself is probably the finest
and best that we've had to date I want
to salute all of you as well as all the
other graduates we also the theme it was
very nicely set by dr. fine today about
diversity and the numbers of people that
are from every place in the world and
how all this diversity gets together and
how in fact they work together so well
and I've often wondered about the
significance of much of that and so I
had some other remarks but it's a good
shook me off a bit and think about
however all these people get along so
well you know in our little microcosm of
the world we've got 17 or 18 different
languages six of them are spoken by lina
but in the world there are sixty eight
hundred and nine different languages in
Europe there are some 230 different
languages spoken in South Asia and
Indochina Indonesia there are two
thousand one hundred and some languages
spoken in Queens as another Michael
there are a hundred and thirty eight
different languages spoken and that's
among several million people in Papua
New Guinea a population of four million
people speaks 832 different languages so
how in fact can this be melded into
groups like this which provide a synergy
to take care of people so well give a
sense of dedication to their work work
constantly and honored everything that
we stand for here
University this wonderful group of
professors and doctors how does this all
happen well it starts someplace in a
very interesting thing that I just
thought of before which was my old
friend Frank Sinatra made us wrote a
song of signing a song many years ago
the house we living and the house be
living the essence of which is
willingness to be together the
willingness to share and common goals
putting aside racial language and
everything else so I want to
congratulate all of you on having
accomplished that so magnificently in
this wonderful University there are too
many of you to say too much about
everybody but another theme that dr.
fine did mention was acknowledgement of
our staff and our staff starting with my
colleague dr. Boyle iris sereno Maria
prolly no Gloria Ortiz Elizabeth Vargas
to the unseen truant Jackie Gonzales
voltage Jenkins Kathleen torrid Griffin
Jeanette Moya Vanessa la bori and common
Montalvo so thank you very much there
are lots of people in the agt program I
had lots to say about each one of you
but there's a compelling imperious note
that i got from dr. fine dr. Lipton saw
be brief I'm never brief but I won't say
it too much about anybody but I'm going
to announce your names and please come
up here as we fill the stage and leave
room to somebody else thank you so dr.
Amit Bulow dr. Cory darling dr. Ozma
al-qassam dr. Catherine casita dr. min
Hyun Kim dr. Jung Jaco dr. lauren corpus
Welch dr. min kwok dr malik that the
kenyan Martinez dr. Jatin Kumar no glory
of the Francis aww dr. Neil Patel dr.
Divya ready Santa Polly dr. Fauci gone
Julio Silva like that time view same to
Violetta skiers like this retro Sony
that the lucy zhang and part 2 j GT two
niacin dr. Mohamed rafa dr wahwah like
the leaner sharma dr. cutting deep
saying thank you here they are
Tom um dr. Boyle please come up stage
hi everybody as many of you know I don't
need a microphone my voice is very loud
they can be here all the way in eighth
floor by now I like to introduce my my
senior resident Lena Sharma she's going
to have a brief speech i don't know it's
like 15 pages so um chill out and we'll
hopefully we'll be done by by dinnertime
ladies and gentlemen I would like to
start with something in Latin I did try
to figure out how to say it but I do
apologize if I don't say it correctly in
women to read a businesswoman I'll
translate that in thy light we shall see
light that is the Latin motor of
Columbia University on behalf of the
graduating class of 2010 I want to take
this opportunity to sincerely thank
those people who have provided the light
of good guidance and mentorship to us
during our time here at Columbia and
I've made our stay at Columbia
educational and memorable Dean Lamster
associate dean fine dr. saliman time dr.
Litton thaw doc determine dr. Boyle
distinguished guests parents and family
and of course my classmates the HDD post
graduates of Columbia School of Dental
Medicine and all fellows of the other
postgraduate programs it is my honor to
speak to you today as a proud member of
the columbia university class of 2010
commencement appears on our university
calendar once a year every year this
event appears on the life calendar of a
graduate only once so be proud as today
represents a lifetime of achievement
today we can gaze upon the future with
hope as faculty family and friends
celebrate the graduate seated here
I would like to take you back to a year
ago when we were all nervously
interviewing without determine and dr.
Lebon ball the interview was a time we
have all discussed many a time in the
lounge and have all reached the same
consensus that dr. Turman was one of the
most relaxing interviews we have had I
recall my interview as i passed the post
office i took a deep breath and tried to
gather my composure before my dental
interview i entered a brick building and
politely asked the uniformed guard
excuse me sir could you please tell me
where the office of dental education is
the guard looked at me for a very long
few seconds and said dear this is not
the dental school this is the armory
historic Center embarrassed I approached
what I passed along the way and
previously thought was the post office
and realized that it was a Columbia
School of Dental Medicine in spite of my
mistake it did not take me very long to
realize that CEO sdn was truly an
exceptional place my classmates and I
are privileged to receive a balanced
education in an intimate and
collaborative environment the kind and
hardworking people in the AGD program
were in my opinion the greatest assets
faculty and administration dr. terming
also known as dr. T who gave us all the
opportunity to learn at one of the most
exciting venues and was always a bit
available to push our knowledge ability
and self-belief one step further dr.
tease lessons are definitely timeless
and strong especially his advice on be
committed but not attached unfortunately
dr. T I have to suddenly say that today
I disagree with you I am committed but I
am attached also dr. Boyle also known as
dr. B who brings a passion for dentistry
and for teaching every single day of the
week we thank you so much doc tomorrow
there you are Jackie Gonzalez our
diligent floor manager who has resolved
more conflicts in the head of the UN the
best group of assistance in any Hospital
anywhere including Elizabeth Julie Maria
and Gladys and our administrative
whizzes cal clean janet Vanessa Mildred
and Natasha you are the true backbone of
our ATV classmates we bring to you this
moment a variety of emotions we arrived
at this day with pride joy uncertainty
and sheer terror as we think of the
combined Colossus of financial debt that
we represent however today we present
commencement in the highest of spirits
ready to take part in one of the most
exhilarating achievements of our life we
gather to pay tribute to our supporters
and to our own toils that span over two
decades we also look to the opportunity
that tomorrow will bring and ask
ourselves what we will bring to tomorrow
as we take the next step in our lives
after a GD I hope all of us will carry
with us the confidence of our rigorous
education and the memories of our
wonderful companionship and shared
expectation experiences today is a
triumph of the staggering battles of the
graduate that have been overcome to
achieve this great goal these battles
unite us today and I hope they will
unite us for a lifetime not only to each
other but also as the alumni of Columbia
University School of Dental Medicine as
we rise up to meet the great challenges
of our time let us do it with a smile
and I am confident that the world will
return the favor congratulations and
thank you
we're now to the certificate in the
general practice residency program dr.
Gregg buns oh I know his residence a
truly loved unfortunately can't be here
this morning so dr. Sidney Isaac will
present them certificates well good
morning first I want to congratulate all
the graduates aren't finishing up their
residency programs and postdoctoral
programs here at Colombian at the
hospital I know that it was long arduous
path but a path well taken i'm going to
call first but first going to talk about
the general practice residents the
general practice residents are I think
the unsung heroes of the hospital dental
service the general practice residency
here is very difficult I'm sure that not
a single resident who was finishing the
program neck new next two weeks thought
that on July first when they arrived
they be taken care of a does an
uncontrolled diabetic intubated on a
ventilator with severe head and neck
infections in the surgical ICU at the
hospital and that was just the start of
their year and that may have been one of
the more healthier patients they dealt
with last summer the general practice
residents are rarely seen on the eighth
floor because when after they take all
in the hospital they have to go home due
to the the 80-hour work week and the 24
plus six our rules that all residency
programs must abide by their day began
if they're wrong call would begin well
it would end at morning rounds but they
always pre rounded at six in the morning
to make sure all is well with our
patients and they were frequently up all
night taking care of calls in the
emergency room and
in and for take care of our impatience
and so I want to call him up dr. Laila
side who can't be here today I think she
must be post call but dr. Laila Assad is
not here today she's gonna be going into
private practice finding backup perhaps
back up in Montreal dr. Mahajan dolly
who was actually our second-year
resident and who really served as an
oral surgery in turn and really kept the
clinic together in the second half of
the year when our first-year oral
surgery residents went off to medical
school he'll be joining us as an oral
surgery resident come July one doctor
and mitsumoto who was just always
pleasant nothing nothing bothered her in
the least she always had that great
smile on her face you know the patient
could be crashing and she'd have that
smile on her face don't worry everything
will be well and i'll be doing pediatric
dentistry up at st. barnabas and the
bronx got de Libertad Negron who came to
us from university of puerto rico also I
think came away with a deep
understanding of the relationship
between medicine and dentistry I believe
she's starting an indo program out in
California and last but not least
Columbia's own doctor Korea Shaheen
who has his way of doing things and many
times he was right and I think he really
helped the general practice residents
get acclimated when they began the
program in the summer and I want or if
him congratulations as well
alright I'll make this quick precise
like the way you usually work on daily
basis this year has been tremendously
good for us we gain a lot of experience
in the hospital doing medical rotation
such as anesthesia emergency department
rotation and treat clean care of all
dental needs of all hospitalized
patients on all the flaws of this huge
hospital give us great confidence in
treating medically compromised patients
it was a tough year I would like to make
special thanks to dr. bonza who is a
very supportive to to us and our
treatment after Isaac was also very
always available for us and and provide
the full dedication of his time to his
residence it was a great pleasure also
to work with my GP Arco residence they
always worked hard and help out in and
every day patience patience care also
special thank you to a supporting staff
and all faculty congrats and thank you
for all the help from all other
graduating residents from other programs
thank
now we come to the certificate pediatric
dentistry if you if you had a design the
ideal program director for pediatric
dentistry I'm sure be dr. Richard you
come on up thanks very much dr. fine
good morning I'm excited to be here
because we have a wonderful group of
graduates to present to you if I could
have our graduates up here on stage
please
thank you in several weeks these folks
will no longer reside here but begin a
career as a specialist in age-defying
field where they see all children from
infancy to adolescents as well as
persons with special healthcare needs
equipped with a continuum of approaches
to care from behavior guidance in an
office setting to care in a hospital
setting this group is composed of
individuals who have demonstrated your
track record of engagement with the
University and it's hospital please take
a look at them as I highlight for you
some of their activities during their
time here scientific abstract present'
asians at our national annual session in
chicago research presentations at our
national leadership conference in
Seattle over 12,000 children cared for
this past year active participation in
university sponsored direct care
externships abroad to rural Jamaica
Dominican Republic Cambodia Guatemala
and Nicaragua peer and editor review
journal publications managing nightcall
impatient consults hospital rotators and
emergency anesthesia and medicine plus
University rotators friends there has
been a tremendous amount of activity
over the last 23 months and I have had
the privilege of watching them mature
from students with concerns at the
levels of the mouth to students with
concerns at the levels of the child the
family and the community embedded now
with that so-called Columbia RNA of
being engaged problem solvers and asking
that single question of what can we do
about it so colleagues friends family
here they are would you step forward as
I call out your name graduate of Boston
school dr. del me acosta
graduate of our college dr. Hannah on
graduate of NYU School and chief this
past year dr. aura caldera graduate of
our college dr. shilpa shaundi wall in
graduate of upenn school dr. sue wong we
are grateful to them for all that they
have done to strengthen this program we
are confident that we leave them in a
strong position as they transition into
their new careers we remain hopeful that
they would stay in touch and find
effective means of engagement now is
alumna and we are proud not only of
their individual accomplishments but on
how they maintain composure and grace
throughout this rigorous process and
although we remain students throughout
our professional lives I believe that it
is unmistakeably clear that something
very special and memorable has occurred
right here thank you and congratulations
if I could have dr. Steven trusted
division director join me
somebody else
I promise I will be brief I just want to
extend a very very very gracious thank
you to our assistance our administrators
very much appreciated dr. Eun dr.
chested thank you for much for giving us
you know the skill set that we need to
embark on the sex chapter of our lives
your mentorship your guidance and past
two years is we're just so we're so
happy um I thought a lot about what
message I wanted to give today and I
thought about my journey over the past
six years four years of dental school
two years of postgraduate training and I
was thinking about how my definition of
success has evolved and what I realize
now is that success is to have meaning
and purpose in your life it's to live
your life with integrity to be honest
not to be something that you're not and
to give back to society in some way and
it's my belief that with professional
accomplishment comes social
responsibility and so I'm very honored
to stand up here representing all these
women who have demonstrated their
commitment to serving and working with
the underserved pediatric population and
I want to leave you with the quote that
I heard once that I it got me thinking
and the quote was from a famous
playwright called Susie Laura parks who
said to always entertain your far out
ideas and anyone who's worked has seen
us work with our pediatric population or
who works with children knows the
lengths that we have to go through to
entertain our patients and to get them
to trust us and have confidence in us
with their families so always remember
to entertain those far out ideas
as his team monitor had said about Dean
Lamster that that he's he's a Dean of
vision and one of his charges also is
that all these programs not only
maintain the highest level of quality
but they continue to be innovative they
continue to push the envelope and expand
and our next program certificate in oral
pathology doctors a guerrilla is the
director now has actually changed that
program actually have an MD component to
keep on elevating the quality that
program doctors agra relly last week
while seeing patients with dr. automa
our graduating resident she reminded me
that today was graduation day and she
said to me you know she said you have to
say something about me and I have to say
something about you
then she said that her brie marks
followed mine and she wanted to know she
said what are you gonna say about me I
said then without a doubt that you're
very pretty and you're very smart no
question about it and she said that she
would say then that I was brilliant and
handsome well i'll be waiting over there
in the chair see if i get that response
regardless we were very fortunate to
have recruited a doctorate omadhaun
teratoma was a very successful clinical
general dentist in Washington State
3,000 miles away she had a very
successful practice with a lot of dental
implants a great deal simply of success
she had a passion though for pathology
and she sold her practice packed her
things and a pickup truck and row 3,000
miles to be our resident hearing and
it's no easy task to do that when you
graduated from dental school back in the
1990's that's not too far I go and then
to enter into a specialty that is truly
bookish you read a lot and you practice
a lot of the microscope and gross
tissues etc heavy duty reading and she
was very very successful and she's ready
to sign our cases now for her future
I've noticed a couple weeks ago without
her hair got a little shorter because
she's going into the United States
military she will be going into the army
in a few weeks and she will be inducted
as a major in the army and she will be
situated in a remote area at least 2,000
miles away from the nearest oral
pathologist she'll be there for three
years on some island called Hawaii so
I think she'll have a good time and
she'll have a great career ahead of her
Michelle
you
I think he outdid me dr. Z you are truly
brilliant and the most handsome mentor
anybody could ever have um I'm just not
realizing how much more fun I could have
had if I if I had a co-president but um
thankfully for you that means I'll keep
this short I don't really know what
possessed me to give it all up after 10
years of practice I had a beautiful
house on the water which I rented out so
I still have it I put my motorcycles in
storage and I trucked it out here and
hope for the best on my first day when I
had the wonderful experience and thrill
of performing our first autopsy I know
it was in for quite a ride and I'm so
glad I did it so it's kind of cold in
here and a little bit nervous that um my
learning experience here has been
phenomenal I spent the last three years
grossing all kinds of organs you
couldn't possibly imagine a dentist
touching and studying them for disease
and pathology I took biopsies on
patients nobody ever saw me I know I
taught some a GD students at one point
but I did a lot of really fun things and
I'm really really glad for the
experience so I just want to take this
opportunity to thank dr. Z for allowing
me such an exciting educational
adventure doctors Yunnan filippone for
all of your encouragement and support
the wonderful ladies of the clinic
Jackie caffee I don't know where you all
are Janet Gladys Norris I don't know if
she's still with us but everybody was
just so wonderful you always made my
experience is so pleasant my parents for
supporting me through every adventure
the past nameless number of years
countless number of years and to all of
you who are graduating most of you have
never met you have a great great great
future ahead of you and if I had such a
wonderful bright future as a general
dentist for a long time just imagine how
wonderful yours just going to be now so
you
every year I'm asked dr. Lewton thought
how do I pick the date when we're gonna
have graduation and they say simply what
we have to do is we got a call the next
program director and ask what's his or
schedule for the month dr. Sidney Isaac
is here to present the certificates in
oral maxillofacial surgery that's
actually true so it gives me a great
pleasure to introduce the two graduates
from the oral and maxillofacial surgery
combined medical degree program at
newyork-presbyterian hospital in
Columbia University Medical Center it
was seven years ago that they were in
dental school yuko was at Case Western
and mugdha was at USC they're getting
their applications ready and they're
wondering and they play couldn't wait
for the interview season to begin
because they'd be traveling far and wide
and spending a lot of money to on their
interviews and I think did you guys
interview on the same day on separate
days so I it's it's rare that it's very
uncommon for me to remember interviews
they have to be very very poor interview
or something very unusual so mugdha came
in and she exhibited such self
confidence without arrogance that we
just knew that here was someone who was
special and you go came in now you go
who was very quiet and a bit shy she has
a black belt in something I have a
yellow streak she has a black belt
and she volunteered to do a thousand
push-ups during the interview and then
she volunteered to take on Tom Wilson
who is also a black belt but Tom also
played fullback for Boston College in
kind and she offered to whip his butt
and we say no we looked at ourselves
when she left we said well I think we
have two people we're going to put high
in the match and so it's now six years
later the program is finished and the
oral and maxillofacial surgery program
is not an easy program they spend a year
on service on the oral surgery service
and then they go up to medical school
here at Columbia which is this is not an
easy medical school they have to
complete essentially three years of
medical school in two years which means
they get no vacation and while they're
going to classes they arrange some of
their fourth year electives for the
afternoons and the weekends to get
things done and then they become general
surgery residents for the for a year and
in general surgery they are general
surgery resident they'll be on the
cardiac service the transplant service
their day doesn't begin and does it end
it's one continuous a wakeful hour which
goes on for 24 plus hours they have to
they'll pre-round on their patients
three in the morning their rounds may
begin at five in the morning with their
senior residents it is a long very very
difficult year and then they come back
for two years thinking they could have a
vacation on oral and maxillofacial
surgery and it is in a vacation you know
our program is a difficult program it's
a demanding program and you know I
watched these two women grow over the
past six years and I am very proud of
them sell me let me bring them up Yuko
Nakamura
love the pet one hand the other way you
go you know they've also why they're
coming up they they have both spent time
on international missions they have been
to Jamaica the Dominican Republic
they've been on cleft trips with myself
and Vinny correo to Nicaragua and
recently to Colombia South America
okay good morning everyone I'd like to
thank all of you for being here and
sharing this day with us so I would just
like to start out with a description of
my co resident you go and I as we begin
our residency and I'm going to do it in
soap format so we have a 20 something
year old girl otherwise healthy present
presenting for her first day of
residency training in oral maxillofacial
surgery she's a bit nervous and she's
completely clueless she she has no meds
or she takes no meds and she has no
allergies her review of systems is
significant for heart palpitations and
mild abdominal discomfort so on exam we
see a well-developed well-nourished
young lady she appears anxious and she's
diaphoretic her head and neck exam is
norma cephalic in a traumatic her chest
is clear her heart is regular rate and
tachycardic and her abdomen is soft
non-tender and non distended with
hyperactive bowel sounds her extremities
are warm and well perfused with tremors
in her upper extremities so now fast
forward to six years later the resident
who is now 30-something presents for her
graduation day she's no longer anxious
and she's much more confident she has
made it through six years of training
including two internships one in general
surgery and she's made it through med
school there have been no other changes
in her medical history and she has no
other changes in her review of systems
this time on her exam she appears
emaciated with sallow skin and dark
circles under her eyes
she has no wrinkle still Thank You Botox
her heart is regular rate in rhythm her
chest is clear but she shows a new
growth of chest hair her abdomen is soft
non-tender and non distended with normal
active bowel sounds her extremities are
warm and well perfused with calluses on
the palmar surfaces of her hands and her
labs are significant for an elevated
level of testosterone so incessant we
have a 30 something year old oral
maxillofacial surgeon who's presenting
here for her graduation she's a little
worse for wear but very very happy to be
here she's made some mistakes along the
way but she's learned from these
mistakes and she's also done quite a few
things right as well she hopes to use
the knowledge and the skills attained in
her residency training to better the
lives of her patients and her plan is
now to go out into the world to start a
practice and hopefully make a big
difference in the lives of the patients
that she treats so in closing I would
like to say a few thank yous I want to
thank all the people who have made all
of this possible for the both of us
first off of course our chairman dr.
Isaac thank you thank you for all of the
wonderful educational opportunities
you've given us all the wonderful trips
to Colombia and Nicaragua Guatemala
Jamaica and thank you for your your
surgical guidance also thank you for
putting up with two standing stools in
the o.r there's quite a big height
difference there thank you to dr. corrao
for all your support dr. joel friedman
Dr holtzmann dr. Mandel dr. levy dr.
Turman and dr. Philip own and all the
rest of our clinic attendings I would
also like to thank our assistance in
particular Estella who
we'll be leaving us this year we love
her very much and thank you to takie
chef for orchestrating our lives for the
past six years and finally thank you to
my mom and to my dad my brothers and my
sister for all your love and support and
thank you you go my co resident who's
been here with me for six long years
thank you all I just want to also have
my husband first affording me and my
family and of course I'm with him ugh
dad I was interesting six years yeah
yeah and also for the hospital staff is
that here for taking care of our
patients and not freedom as well thank
you
also under the deans guidance as time
goes on we're actually going to be
adding more postdoc programs so this
ceremony is going to get longer and
longer longer look at dr. garvik on this
but that completes the certificate in
masters part of the program now I'm
going to bring up the vice dean for
academic affairs dr. Salim time these
are closing remarks and they will also
be brief I would like to add my
congratulations to all of you on this
really special day the graduates most of
you have now completed their formal
education it's not much more that we can
teach you in a formal curriculum from
this point forward you will be on your
own you will infect direct your own
education as you are going to do your
independent learning and setting out
your own continuing education programs
we hope that many of those continuing
education programs will be with us so
that we can see you and see how things
are happening and how you're doing in
your lives also we know we kind of tie a
little rope on you we kind of every now
never like to pull you in so continuing
education programs is going to be
something that we look forward to as you
come back to us a life full of promise
really lays ahead of you you have the
basic preparation to become the very
best in your field and we all look
forward to your success in your
respective specialties and then comes
the second part of that little rope that
we have tied on to you we hope that in
your future years you will share your
expertise with new generations of
students that are going to be in our
programs and if you're in New York City
we hope you will be with us ok now that
kind of leads directly into the next
part of what i'm going to say because
one of my really pleasant duties is to
make an award the for mccollough award
for excellence in teaching
it has become customary at this ceremony
to honor one of the members of the
volunteer faculty who contribute so much
to our post doctoral programs you may
have heard their names being mentioned
as various thank you thank yous were
made any educational program depends to
a significant extent on the excellence
of its teachers in our programs we are
blessed by having a group of master
clinicians who has volunteers generals
generously share not only the time but
more importantly their expertise with
our residents and students some years
ago we established a former Cola Award
for Excellence in teaching the award is
named after dr. alan j for McCollough
who led the college as its dean for 23
years and the recipient of this year's
award i would like to ask him to come up
is dr. Aaron Levie
so I'm going to say all the nice things
about him right now okay dr. Levey has
been taking advantage of the various
burrows that new york city offers he had
his received his BA degree from Queens
College in Flushing New York he received
his dds degree from New York University
College of Dentistry then he completed
the one-year residency in anesthesiology
it at my manatees Medical Center in
Brooklyn then he went on to complete his
residency in oral maxillofacial surgery
at Metropolitan Hospital Center in New
York and between 1983 and 1989 he
co-directed the oral surgery training
program at the Jacobi hospital in the
bronx the only thing that he didn't do
was go to Staten Island I don't know why
dr. Levey is one of those few private
practitioners who has dedicated himself
to resident education for many years
while maintaining a private practice he
co-directed Jacoby residency program
until it merged with the montefiore
medical center Irving has been on the
staff in our column Irving now she is at
Columbia he has been on the staff at
Columbia for about six years and he
helps instill in the residence and then
for students the importance of lifelong
learning by example and evidence-based
practice he has been the force behind
the growth in the implant reconstruction
efforts of the division and he tends
clinic every Wednesday this is quite a
commitment and the final statement which
is as I was gathering the statements
that mate Dr leaf he so very special
this one I loved best of all his quiet
calm manner in our very busy clinic is
like the eye of a hurricane and I
thought there was a beautiful
description that that I think says it
all so I'm proud and honored to present
this year's
wacoal Award for Excellence in teaching
to dr. urban leave me
two final things you really can't have a
event like this go I think as smooth as
it goes every single year without
several individuals actually behind the
scenes working real hard to do this and
thats starts with melissa welsh in the
back there and for assistant alex
borstein in the back and also yo Londell
antigua and elsa solace from the dean's
office now for us up here it ends but
for all of you now we have another party
waiting and it's across the street at 50
haven in guard halt to be a celebration
now for all of you to go ahead and
attend which basically starts in five
minutes so i thank you all for coming
this morning and wish you all well
you